hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Adele and
we're gonna watch the trailer today for
the giver the giver that's what I that's
what I am Adele you're a giver
I'm a giver talking sexual was I like to
I use my hands make my way down south if
you know what I mean I really don't know
what you mean to explain it going going
down on my girl eating out cutting
Lingus felishj you oh my god and I'm
hoping this is what this movie is about
yeah even though I know a lot of kids
read this book in school I think so
let's watch this creator Jamal has been
asking me to watch this for months now
so yeah I'm here for you buddy
you created Jamal won two communities
injective serene beautiful places where
disorder became harmony oh so it's like
divergent in the Hunger Games
let's go
activity
there's something something that has
been stolen there has to be a way so
that you can stop this you could change
things
everyone yeah I mean it kind of makes
sense to me
the giver I mean isn't that what so
they're giving them injection so they
can well I thought the givers I thought
the giver was a person to remind them in
the past and stuff like that and okay
then they explained that in the trailer
I think I tuned out yeah at first it
looked like a bunch of young adult
novels like The Hunger Games and
divergent and even the hosts as a
trailer progressed it seemed like it got
a little better per scene it's just
marketed about tweens
yeah age group the divergent market
right yeah yeah but I
the main guy does not look like a very
good actor yeah I mean Jeff Bridges and
Meryl Streep are great actors fantastic
actors Katie Holmes looks pretty good in
that I think between Jeff Bridges Meryl
Streep and Katie Holmes Katie Holmes is
without a doubt the number one actress
between the three yep these are facts
everyone respects her yeah I don't know
about the main guy I know who he is but
he seems like he has limited expressions
yeah I mean it would make sense but even
when he has emotion it's like he's meant
to be the one guy who does have a movie
yeah I mean I saw a movie years ago
called
equilibrium I'm sure this book was
written before that at equilibrium had a
similar plot which was like you know
society and people get injections to
numb their emotions
that's a cool plot device but I don't
know I mean it really all depends upon
the execution of this film I like the
things I can see why it would be a
schoolbook that thing about class
segregation or like mm-hmm
controlling the masses big brother-type
I don't know it just kind of seems like
a little bit repetitive of all these
young adult novels that's cuz it's what
scene right now
especially with like Meryl Streep being
a she like the villain in this looks
like it wasn't Caitlyn look the villain
that version wasn't there a bad female
lead in yeah I mean no it's based on
books but still looks like this is best
thing in the future the females will be
superior mm-hmm I think so too
I mean if you notice the the word Giver
the middle of it was a giant vagina
woman win
so anyway guys if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe give to us by
subscribing
you might see a subscription mm-hmm and
you can give Adele a subscription to to
her channel roll credits roll see what I
did there
imagine what else this Dunkin do I'm a
giver I'm gonna give some shoutouts here
Jack Nicholson I want a shout-out and if
you do give me one well you should be a
model
yeah I should be a model I should I mean
I got the body shape I mean look at this
look at this I can make this bounce I
can make this bounce ago you have to
leave something to the imagination
yeah I got nothing to leave to the
imagination I left it to everyone's
imagination I would greatly disappointed
to be upfront about what I look like
right away
terrible got no action in months but
yeah Jack Nicholson I'm happy you
subscribe to me you're a legend that's
pretty cool that's pretty cool I mean
you did like the bucket list the pledge
wolf all of your biggest movies is what
I just named I got nothing man I think
that's your clothes on this champion
well yes slow motion you just got a
slow-motion shout out slow motion I like
to take things slow to you when I'm
giving you know you gotta you got to
really read the person you know
sometimes they want a fast heart but you
know at the end of the day it's really
everyone's unique and you gotta be able
to read the body well if you're gonna be
a giver yeah vagina
there you go he said it and now I got an
erection
thanks slow motion stroke my chicken too
I want to shout out because I love you
oh dude I love you too Oh gladly Stroke
your chicken giver after all
yeah stroke it twice who knows maybe I
am I like it more than stroking it twice
so yeah maybe a double stroke your
chicken Adele come on be a little bit
ladylike and I will give you a shout-out
and I love you too you won't touch his
chicken yeah what the heck Adele come on
you said he loves me I know that was
really nice yeah it's worthy of stroking
his chicken really gosh Adele's not a
giver just a receipt oh really
anyway I love you too buddy